it says let's get the right screen first
the secretary starts on an annual salary
of $30,000 with annual increments of
$2,000 okay so that's a pretty simple
set up now the first thing that I would
encourage you to do it's not necessary
but it's sort of like the this series of
sequences equipped if equivalent of
drawing a diagram I want you to write
with me there are two numbers in here
and each of them has it a significant
meaning I want you to write those with
me so that you don't have to refer back
to the question when you're actually
doing the working okay so what are the
two numbers and what do they refer to
give me the first one $30,000 now before
I write down $30,000 I want to know what
it is I don't want this to be a string
of disconnected numbers and equations
I want words just like the question uses
words to tell me what's going on so what
is 30,000 what does it signify it's the
it's the first it's the starting salary
that's what it is so I'm just going to
write that starting salary 30,000 little
point of trivia I used to put commas in
between you know when you got big
numbers like 30 million or something
like that or 30 thousand I used to put
commas between the groups of three and
that's a pretty Australian convention
but then I learned that in Europe they
use commas to indicate decimal points so
that's thirty dollars in Europe which is
weird and confusing it's it's sort of
like driving on the right-hand side of
the runners to the left-hand side the
road let's just let's just be different
for differences sake so that's why
you'll find I don't write covers in
between my things I just write gaps I
just a little point it's not like you're
ever gonna be submitting this to some
mathematician in Europe but um
surprisingly all kinds of people watch
this video so I'm gonna be a little more
conscious of it that's the sani salary
what was that other figure it's
important
mm now what would you call that it's
that it's the it's the pay rise
it's the increase I think the word is
that use what increment is that the way
they use so that's not a very common
word but it's worth getting used to
because you'll see it in this topic
increment just means this is what it's
going up by each time
so mm if I recall all right so we have
the setup
there's our diagram so now they ask us
two questions
what's the first question Maria with me
part a find his annual salary and his
total earnings at the end of 10 years so
it's a bit of a double-barreled question
okay both of them though Part A both
parts of this question have to do with
at the end of 10 years so I'm gonna
write that now you might think it's
slightly excessive that I used so many
words
trust me the classic error of students
in this topic is that they don't use
enough words I know we try to be concise
but by doing too many shortcuts even
something like at the end of 10 years
rather than straight in 10 years
believe me it makes a difference okay
what are the two things they're asking
for I think they're ask you for what is
the salary is that right
what is the salary and what are his
total earnings meaning at the end of the
tenth year what has he earned in that
year and then at the end of the tenth
year
what has he earned all over you 1 2 3 4
5 etc ok so let's just do them one at a
time
what is his salary well how are we going
to work this out we know where it starts
$30,000 and it's going to increase at
the other 10 years how many times we'll
have increased
yeah well year one will be 30,000 and
then you two will be that plus 2,000
then you 3 will be plus 2,000 again plus
2,000 again so in total you will have
added 9 lots of the pay rise does that
make sense that's n minus 1 does that
ring a bell so this is 9 times 2,000
yeah are you happy with that so this is
nice and you don't even need a
calculator for this part we will shortly
so this is 30,000 plus 18,000 do you
need to write this in between line
before you get to the next one
probably not but it's incumbent on you
to communicate clearly what is going on
and I don't see this huge time-saving
and I just don't trust my own arithmetic
if I went straight to the answer
but I'm happy with this said okay my
numbers alright quick sense check does
it make sense it's a reasonable number
it's increased it has a decreased it's
in the right ballpark happy okay that
was the first part of a what's the
second part where they ask you for yeah
total wealth how much has he accrued
over this time right so I guess we would
use the phrase they use which is total
earnings let me say it again use words
please don't just make this like X or Y
or even worse just the numbers on their
own these are two completely separate
things so tell me that they're two
completely separate things
the total earnings are made up of his
first year's income and his second and
its third because apparently in this
weird world of a question he's a boring
person who spends no money so we start
with the first one and because we're
doing all ten years right well we know
what happens in the next year there's an
increment of two thousand right I'm
trying to form a pattern here so think
back to series and sequences how many
terms do I need to form of Hattin three
and you can see this series is starting
to form I've got one two three terms
it's not an infinite series though it
has an end so even though I go dot dot
dot I'm going to finish at a final term
what's the final term yeah I just worked
this out right this is why there's an
order to it so I'm going to finish at
48,000 okay now a little minor note here
you have formed an AP right do you
recognize it it's going up by the common
difference and I'm going to rather just
add them all up because I have a
calculator but I don't really want to
punch in ten numbers I'm going to use
the fact that I know how to work out the
sum of an AP in order to use the formula
I want to save that I know where this is
coming from so I'm actually going to and
I'm literally going to do this on the
side I'm going to say this is an AP like
I'm going to say that phrase later on
when we entered enta fide geometric
progressions I'll say this is a GP right
what kind of features define an AP there
are three particular things there's the
first term
which in this case is good Val there's a
common difference which in this case is
mm and then there's the number of terms
yep oh sorry that's I'm just thinking of
different numbers in my head and then
there's the number of terms right
how many champs 10 10 years I could
write N equals 10 at this point but I'm
going to not I'm gonna write 10 terms
instead if you wait about 3 lessons
you'll see why I didn't write N equals
10 just remind me if I don't say it ok
so I have everything I need
now I have two choices here and there
are two ways to state the sum of an AP
do you remember what the two ways are
let's write it up the top sum of the
first n terms there are two different
formulas for it I'll give you a clue
they both start with an on two before
you tell me the rest of the formula do
you know why they both start with n on
two what does n on two like it
represents this little algebraic
numerical trick that we did in here when
we were trying to come up with this
formula if there are 10 terms and on two
of course is what in this case it's 5
what's the significance of 5 to this do
you remember how we came up with an AP
remember we did this and then we did
this I'm missing the one that's there
and then we did this so what am i doing
I'm I'm pairing up and then I meet in
the middle and each one of the pair's
equals the same amount right so this is
the number of pairs if you were to match
everything up now there are two things
that come after this there are two
different versions here's a long one and
here's a short one oh I think back and
you do have this on your reference rate
I should point out but as extension one
students I don't think you should need
the reference chief for this one have I
have I brought you enough time to try
and remember what the sum of an AP is
and you'll want to try either one either
one is fine
yeah Shalini
to a plus n minus one D now that now
before we explain where this comes from
it might help if anyone remembers the
shorter one because it explains where
all the terms come from in this one
first pasta last which do you remember I
pointed this out before the first term a
is the first letter the alphabet but
because we love being inconsistent we
call the last one L hole usually because
anyway okay so now you can see where
this comes from
right you see where it is one of these
A's is this but of course the last term
will be a plus n minus one D it's the
last term one lot of the beginning and
then n minus one lots of the difference
so tell me which of these which you
prefer to use in this case because you
really can use either I think I'll use
the second one it's just less numbers
right so I've got turn on - there's my n
on - they both have it here's my first
term and then here's my last term now
one of the phrases you might hear is
that you want to write this solution
such that someone who doesn't know what
you're doing can see where your logic is
and this is why I bothered to write this
if you just saw this and then it went
straight to this line that looks like
magic to me like how where what we've
done a lot of work to know why that is
the case and we have that as a formula
it's established but to know that you
can use this formula you want to justify
the fact that this is the K piece of
information that it's an AP so I can use
the AP formula okay what are we got here
five by 78,000 mmm I was in a you rate
lesson yesterday which taught me some
methods to think about how to break this
apart rather than resort to using my
calculator 5 times 7 is 35 so that's
350,000 the aid will give me 40,000 so I
think that's three hundred and ninety
thousand and that's in dollars are you
happy with that now of course you know
you have a calculator there but the
reason why I'm pushing on this is
because when I look at this I can do it
in my head and the more you do things in
your head
the more you'll be able to work out
later when you do use a calculator is
that answer reasonable or not like if
your brain can't do it then you've got
no chance really of knowing whether in
the right track or otherwise that was
part a how's your brain going like are
you okay remembering this ap stuff none
of this is new like you you knew this
you knew those you just need to remember
them and apply them to this context that
was question a can you have a look at B
for me I've warmed you up can I give you
a couple of minutes Head Start to try
and interpret it work out what kind of
knowledge you would use to try and solve
that question and then we'll do it on
the board together just have it got a
puppy I gave you a head start it's quite
all right if you're not there yet but
there aren't too many lines of working
here the key is to work out what piece
of knowledge will help you actually form
the right equations so they ask you I
think from memory what year what exact
year will he get to is it forty to forty
two thousand dollars as his annual
salary right so what piece of what
arithmetic progression knowledge might
are going to use here it's a lot about a
sum it's about a particular term right
so do you remember what the formula is
for the particular term we actually
refer to it like two minutes ago a plus
yep so you can say this either way codes
multiplication but we tend to say it
like this because we mean that many lots
of the common difference okay now we
have values for each of these we want
the salary that's the term to be 42,000
yeah
and we know what all the other pieces
are with one exception what's the piece
we're actually trying to find and so
let's put in all the other bits this is
30 this is the part that you don't know
it and then my common difference of
course is still 2,000 so it's just
routine algebra from here you just need
to change the subject but you might as
well help me through it take away 30
from both sides so that leaves you with
12 dozen now what do you do well divide
I might as well get the end back on the
left hand side where it belongs so that
gives you 6 and then you have an answer
okay probably worth noting
again the question is inwards so I
should at least provide my answer in
words probably this is the minimum I
would expect a sentence would be nicer
and will become more important later on
when you actually need to describe what
is happening and not just provide a time
okay but dur make sense was that all
right